I never want to play that part my offer
is this nothing that was Francis that
got me to do it because Francis always
wanted me to be okay I was who he saw in
that room talking to me completely
fought for me my father made him an
offer he couldn't refuse and it was
downhill after that because nobody else
wanted it Paramount didn't want me or
Brando
do other things it was really uh and the
struggle was greatly his he had a
struggle for me ever since then I
thought that's really what a director is
interested in you for a part that means
something I've decided to be Godfather
you go through a period when you become
well known or you've become what is
known as bankable you start to if it's
dubious because you don't know whether
somebody wants you because they see you
in the point or because you can make the
movies but the best time is when a
director wants you just when I thought I
was out they pulled me back in